بدا انسحاب الاحتلال العسكري في هذه
الاثناء من مخيم نور شمس بعد عمليه عسكريه
استمرت لساعات طويله اكثر من ع ساعات على
العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال في مدينه
طول كرم ادت لارتقاء عدد من الشهداء ايضا
كان هناك عدد من الاصابات على وقع هذه
العمليه العسكريه نرصد هنا في هذه الصوره
بدء تحرك لعشرات الاليات العسكريه هنا في
هذه المنطقه كما تشاهدون حيث بدات بدا
الانسحاب لعشرات الاليات العسكريه باتجاه
حاجز 104 او ما يسمى بتسن عوز بعد يعني
عمليه عسكريه ونرصد هنا احدى الاليات
العسكريه على ما يبدو انها معطوبه بفعل
العبوات الناسفه التي فجرت بالاليات
العسكريه وجنود جيش الاحتلال الان بدا
فعلا الانسحاب لبعض الاليات العسكريه فيما
لا يزال البعض الاخر من تلك الاليات
متواجد ب في محيط مخيم نور شمس حتى هذه
اللحظه عره ساعات على العمليه العسكريه
تخللها اشتباكات مسلحه في عده محاور
وايضا يعني تفجير لعشرات العبوات الناسفه
باليات الاحتلال العسكريه من مدينه طول
كرم ليث جعار
الجزيره